[Music]  PBS sure about this PBS admitted that  during their live broadcast of fireworks  in Washington they edited in  pre-recorded footage of fireworks from  previous years yeah I guess it was a  cloudy night on Monday night and in  Washington it was kind of hard to see  the live fire works so PBS just edited  in old footage and tried to pass it off  as being the fireworks that were  happening live which you don't expect  from PBS no not at all  yeah a lot of people were angry I was  one of them I was there watching because  I love the PBS firework I know it's like  I can tell these are alive this is  fascinating but you know when you really  look at it and I did I went back and  looked you know I don't see how PBS got  away with it  in the long run take a look  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  you